a woman yesterday ashley babbitt mother
military veteran 14-year veteran
um uh went to the the protest she was at
the capitol
she was in the capitol building and i'm
you've probably seen the video i'm not
to play it here if you haven't it's
extremely upsetting i mean you're
watching somebody die right in front of
you but
she tries to climb over a broken door
she's unarmed and they shoot her and
kill her okay
that's what so you're telling us that
that's that's going easy on them
to shoot and kill them no here's here's
what we know
here's what we actually know is the
truth
if that was a blm protest and that was a
black woman rather than a white woman
the outrage today from the media would
be
nuclear i'm telling you if it was the
exact
same situation exact same
but they're they're carrying blm flags
and she's
black instead of white the outrage today
would be like i don't think
anything you've ever seen we all know
that and there'd be more rioting in
in response to it instead is there any
outrage nobody cares
media doesn't care if anything they're
justifying it openly they're
they're celebrating it you look at what
some leftists on twitter are saying
about it
they're happy it happened
so that's the truth and i'm just not
going to sit here and be lied to i'm
sorry
because the game we're supposed to play
as conservatives you know what we're
supposed to do today what the media
tells us we're supposed to do today
is uh just you know someone like myself
let's sit in front of the camera and say
i condemn
what happened yesterday i condemn it
unequivocally and that's all i have to
say
i just condemn it it's the worst thing
that's ever happened in the country
and uh nobody is to blame at all for it
except the people doing it
nothing led up to it we can't talk about
anything else we're just going to talk
about how bad this one thing was
i'm not playing that game
because that's a lie and i'm i'm not
doing it
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated